I'm Ed Bruce and I'm a Scout Master with Troop 38 in North Falmouth, Massachusetts.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thanks, Clark. And now for you, Scout Master
Ladies and gentlemen, back by popular demand, this story of two penguins in a canoe in the
desert. So let me repeat: two penguins in a canoe in the desert. And one penguin says
where's your paddle? And the other penguin says: yes, it really does, doesn't it?
You got to think about this one. It's a real head scratcher, isn't it? It's crossed a
furor of comment and questions. The first time we mentioned it that I thought we've
got to bring this one back. So there you are. Hey, this is podcast over 196.. Hey
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master podcast. This is Clark Green. Let's zip right over to the
mailbag and let's see here. Julio Roman is an assistant scout master of Troop 1959 in Puerto
Rico And he wrote in to say: me and my wife have been listening to the podcast since number
174.. I was listening to the last podcast, number 195, and heard the announcement of the app for
Android devices. I downloaded it and finally got to listen to the first 20 podcasts. The app is
very friendly and easy to use. Linking the blog and your Twitter and Facebook feeds was a great
idea. My Troop is a relatively new one and we are slowly but surely moving along. Your podcast
has been a lot of help, at least for me as an assistant scout master. Thanks for everything.
Thank you, Julio. Thank you for the kind words. I'm glad you're enjoying the app and we're
going to talk a little bit more about that in a moment. Paul Simonetti got in touch with us via
Facebook and said: Clark, I feel like I know you well. I will soon accept the Scout Master position
and I have used your podcast as an important component of training. I completed the introduction
to outdoor leadership skills and Boy Scout leader specific. I've got all that taken care of,
but it's still my opinion that listening to 125 of your podcast has merit, and with
the remaining 70 or so already on my MP3 player, I will be caught up Now. when I catch up, I want a
signed training card from you as proof. Then I will be a heck of a good interview as the
first Scout Master who used your podcast as official training. Well, Paul, I don't think we're
allowed to call this official training, but you know, we might come up with an unofficial training
card. And Paul went on to say: here's a joke about your opening jokes. I was talking to my son about
scouting and I offered him a few of the jokes from your podcast. I told him about the penguins and
camping in tents at the time the bear left and he looked at me and said, dad, those jokes are wrong
on so many levels. Thanks, Paul, thanks for continuing to stay in touch and I'm so happy to hear
that you are going to jump into the volcano and be a Scout Master. I think that's great
and if you're wondering folks about the penguins and the camping in tents and the bear leaving,
you just have to go back to the old podcast and listen to those. It may be worth your time
and it may not. You'll have to be the judge. We heard from Rob Glazier, who is with Troop 18 in
Muskeko, Wisconsin, again this week. Clark, it's my pleasure to support Scout Master CG as a backer.
I definitely have gotten far more from the blog and podcast than I'm giving back, but I just read
thoughts on scouting and I'm looking forward to the scouting journey. Thanks, and keep on traveling.
Thank you, Rob. Michael Harrington wrote in to say I can't tell you how much I'm looking
forward to your new book. I've been a Scouter for 14 years. I've been a Scout Master and a
crew advisor for the last two and a half years and I was an assistant Scout Master prior to that.
I didn't completely get it until I started to read your blog and listen to the podcast.
Thanks for all you do. You've helped my Scouts and my Troop experience
scouting along the way as it was truly meant to be by helping me see the complete picture.
I've always believed in the patrol method and you made things click for me.
I've since taught my Round Table Scouts what I've learned and I've also sent them to scoutmastercgcom
as a must-go Scouter site. Thanks so much, Michael. Thanks for your kind words of support
and thanks for becoming a backer. Our old pal, Steven Jarvis, is in Fayetteville,
Arkansas, and he is an assistant Cub Master with PAC46 and he wrote in to say I was excited to
see the details on your new book and the new backer program and I was quick to sign up.
I've been listening to your podcast since the beginning and reading your blog longer than that.
I became a Scouter when my son entered as a Tiger Cub over four years ago and now I've been
a Dent Leader and a Cub Master and an Assistant Cub Master and my son's about to move on from
weeblos into Scouts and the Troops invited me to be an Assistant Scout Master. All the accumulated
years of listening to your podcast and reading your blog is going to prove invaluable as I
move on to my next phase as a Scouter. I have a much better idea of what to expect and what they
should expect of me. Thank you for that, Thanks, Steve, and thanks for being in touch and continuing
to comment on the blog and to add to the conversation. it always means a great deal.
So last week, on podcast 195, we announced the new backer program and I'm really pleased and
heartened and frankly, touched by the response. Funds from backers go towards the expenses of
producing and publishing the blog and the podcast and the videos that a lot of Scouts feel are a
valuable resource, and you can become a backer too. Go to scoutmastercgcom. I have some
premiums prepared there and a more in-depth explanation of how your support is applied.
As I'm recording this podcast, it is November 18th 2013 and by the end of the month we will be
shipping backer premiums out, including a Kindle e-book edition of my new book, The Scouting
Journey and thoughts on scouting that was published earlier this year, and autograph copies of the
two of those are also premiums. and you go on to scoutmastercgcom, follow the link to the
backer page and you'll get all the details about exactly how that works. and I want to make sure
to recognize the folks that have become backers this past week. So, in no particular order, thank you
to Alan Shrivner and Bill McMahon and Bruce Johnson and Dave Goldenberg, David Wilkes,
Donald Fowler, Gant Edmondson, Gary Curry, Hutron, James Chaplin, Gerald Dosh,
Jim Gilligy, John Donut, John Nelson, John Weibke, Michael Duff, Michael Harrington, Rob Glaser,
Steven Jarvis, Tamothio Zepeda, Tom Lotito, William Parker and William David Levesque.
Thank you so much for making this first week of the backer program so very successful
and for your support, and I hope I did a reasonably good job with all the names.
If I mispronounced, you know, get in touch and I'll fix that. and in the continuing saga of making
the scouting journey into an actual book with you know, pages and a cover, and we're well along the way
and I'm confident that it's going to be ready for purchase on Amazon by the end of the month
and we'll make sure to have a Kindle edition available too, and I'm looking forward to being
able to tell you that it's finally done in many, many ways. Also, last week, we announced the beta edition
of the ScoutmasterCGcom app, which you can find in the Google Play Store. So far, we've made it
available for Android devices, but we'll make sure that we get it on iTunes when we've got things
taken care of a little bit. I appreciate the feedback that I received this week from those of
you who downloaded the app. It's a free app. It features the blog and our Facebook and Twitter feeds
and, of course, the podcast, with a growing library of the podcast archive. So you'll be able to
access all of what we have to offer through the app, and I've got some good suggestions of
things that can be added to it. We're trying to debug a couple of things before I advertise it
any wider than just announcing it and talking about it here on the podcast. Get the app and let me
know how it works for you. So the remainder of this podcast is going to be taken up with a
discussion of Scoutings- positive rights of passage in Scout Master Ship in seven minutes or less,
and then we've got some email questions to answer. So let's get started. shall we
Scout Master Ship in seven minutes or less?
I wanted to take just the opportunity to talk about, and maybe expand on a little,
a recent post on the blog called Scoutings- positive rights of passage, and what I want
to emphasize is our role in making sure that these rights of passage have a positive spirit
behind them. Now, in the post I use the example of a backpacking trip. A scout who goes out on their
first backpacking trip, or even their first scout camp out of any kind, is leaving the
familiar comforts of home and they're striking out on the trail. They are really have little
idea what to expect. This is all new to them and they're going to go through a series of
challenges and difficulties and they're going to experience these things with a little apprehension
and great joy and excitement as well. What will happen is at the end of that weekend
they will have been through kind of a right of passage. Now, a right of passage has
three kind of distinct steps to it. The first step is the separation from things that are
familiar. You know, a scout packs his gear and ends up in a campsite, somewhere that
they may or may not be familiar with, but they're separated from the comforts of
home and that kind of support system that they always depend on. and there they are.
The next step in a right of passage is transition. There's a period of uncertainty
and vulnerability If they go through challenges and encounter difficulties along the way.
the final step is the accomplishment of that goal of passing through this series of events,
and we want that accomplishment always to be positive. We want the experience through the
transition period and the period of separation that they experienced to be very positive.
We may be familiar with the experience of, you know, packing our things and leaving home and
going camping. We may be assured of the support system that we have there, in the knowledge
and experience that we have, but we have to always remember that for a scout this can be
a tremendous challenge and we need to appreciate that they volunteered to do this
and enter into this kind of right of passage. So how do we make sure that this sort of
experience is a positive one for young people? Well, we're familiar with that kind of movie
stereotype of the harsh, insulting military officer who's tough on his recruits. and that
officer does that because, you know, they have a deeper knowledge of the idea that they need to
make them tough and resilient because of what they're going to face. We begin to understand
why they're so harsh and demanding and difficult. I mention this because that seems to be the
stereotype that some scouts feel is an appropriate one to take with scouts. I've got to tell you that
it is not. You are not there to be tough and demanding and harsh to your scouts. You're there
to be supportive, You're there to be encouraging and you're there to make sure that they remain
safe and happy as they pass through these difficulties. Now, every young person wants
to belong to something that's bigger than themselves and be accepted by the group.
That desire is so strong and so instinctual that it blurs the lines between good and bad.
sometimes Young people are so desperate to become accepted They can be coerced into doing
negative or destructive things. I think that's easy to see, you know, in the example of something
like a street gang or something like that. but obviously scouting is an antidote to that kind
of negative, destructive behavior. The attitude that we apply to work with our scouts is a key
in making these things positive. Now, perhaps you're a scouter and you experienced as a scout, or you
experienced as a young person, that kind of hazing and harshness and discouragement
that was meant to strengthen you and meant to make you into a man or something like that.
but scouters never stoop to hazing or harshness or discouragement. How you experience the rights
of passage that you went through will inform your reaction Now. maybe you receive support
and affirmation and perhaps you're met with that kind of discouragement and harshness.
Our instinctive reactions to these situations may be positive or negative, but as scouters
we check our negative instincts and we champion those positive, affirming and encouraging rights of
passage. We're never harsh or disapproving, but unfailingly supportive and understanding. when
the going is tough and our scouts efforts look less than encouraging, we maintain a positive
outlook. We trade discouragement for honest praise. We trade demeaning, abusive hazing
or initiations for simple ceremonies that honor accomplishment. It's important that we're expressing
honest encouragement, not just dispensing platitudes or disingenuous praise. To be honestly
encouraging, we have to strive to understand the scale of the challenge from each individual
scout's perspective, whether they're bold and outgoing and enthusiastic or they're
tend more to be a little shy and meek and fearful. We never belittle or demean a scout's effort,
even if we're just kind of joking around with them What we intend as good-natured ribbing.
that could be a really difficult thing for a scout to deal with. Put the best face on every
step forward and support each scout's effort towards the goal and do it in a positive
manner, and that's how you turn the challenges and the difficulties that scouts are supposed
to encounter into a positive rite of passage.
Yeah, you are always on the beat boy, beat boy. I'll hang it in. a sweet boy, a sweet boy.
We re-dancing to the beat boy, beat boy. Yeah, you're my favorite all-time boy scout.
You're my favorite all-time boy scout. He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
Write me a letter, send it my name Email. that is folks, And here's an answer to one of your emails.
This email comes in from someone who asked me to withhold their names, so I will do so.
I have a question regarding advancement. We have a scout who advanced to second class within
the first few months of joining the troop, but there's a problem with the first class requirements.
He's not a swimmer. He's 13,, does well in school, has his black belt at martial arts,
but won't get into the water. I know that there are sometimes options to requirements.
Is there any options so that this scout can earn first class without passing the BSA swimming test?
Well, if we're talking about a young man who is simply reluctant to get in the water,
who may be afraid of it if he's not identified or diagnosed with some specific difference or
disability that would disallow that on a medical basis, then we're talking about somebody who needs
to overcome their fear of the water. If you do a little research, you'll find- maybe at the local
Y or at the school or maybe through your scouting contacts, the swimming instructor who
is skilled at dealing with this very difficulty and will be able to help your scout overcome
his reluctance to do this. There are alternative requirements available for scouts who have a
difference or disability that absolutely precludes them from achieving the normal requirements.
If you have a scout with the capacity, mentally and physically, to be able to get in the water and
complete the first class swimming test, but he's just reluctant to do so, I don't think it's
appropriate to try to apply the alternative requirements there. I want to send you to the
resource and that is the Guide to Advancement 2013.. Take a look at what it has to say about
alternative requirements to see if they may apply in this case. Gary Curry is a scout master
with Troop 15 in Charlotte, North Carolina, and he got in touch to ask this question. The BSA
describes new scout patrols and regular patrols and venture patrols and further defines a patrol as
a group of boys that are similar in age, rank and interests. more or less, From some of the
writings on your blog and some of the comments, I'm under the impression that regular patrols exist
all the time and that after the first year, new scouts will be joining an existing regular patrol.
Do I have that right? Normally, working with the senior patrol leader, a weeblos then will
crossover and become a new scout patrol with a troop guide attached to it. Then we usually
have them stay together for the rest of their scouting career because they know each other.
They become a regular patrol when we get to the next set of crossovers.
Are patrols supposed to be permanent and how are scouts assigned to patrols? Well, Jerry,
I don't think you're really missing anything. What the BSA explains is a good basis. It can be a
little confusing because it seems to offer some definitions that may be at odds with my best
advice at times, but it may be helpful just to think of patrols as patrols. You, like me,
think the best way to form and occasionally reform patrols is letting the scouts figure out
what works best for them. Patrols aren't really a management structure to make things convenient
for us. They are the heart of what we do in scouting. Sometimes they last a year or two.
Sometimes they last many more years than that, It depends. The natural gang of friends is what
works for scouts and it should stay that way for as long as it works for them. Sometimes it's
all scouts of the same age, Sometimes it's a little mixed up, but what's important is
is that a scout is happy in their patrol and they get the real work of scouting done.
Everything else well, you know it helps administratively, but it's so much window dressing,
my opinion. I do something similar to what you do when a new group of scouts cross over from
weeblos. They usually choose to be in their own patrol and an older scout helps them out
for a period of time And then, when they are familiar with the way a patrol works,
that older scout will move on and let them run their own patrol on their own. So I think the
most important takeaway is whenever we discuss patrols is they are strongest and most permanent
and best when scouts choose rather than being assigned to patrols. I hope that helps.
Katie is with the Torshalla Scout Corps in Sweden and she writes in to say:
you're fantastic. You make me laugh and you make me think. You make me realize that sometimes
I don't always do everything I should. Well, Katie, I think that's true of any of us,
isn't it? My question is this: I'm a scout leader in Sweden and fairly new to the scouting thing.
My group are eight and 10 year olds. Therefore, although I learn a lot from your
podcast about scouting in general, I need someone that's focused more on the younger
scouts, who shouldn't necessarily be left alone with a box of crayons, Never mind a box of matches.
They're kind of unfocused and messy and loud, but they're also enthusiastic about life and
learning. I want to be able to take that enthusiasm and energy to use it to create the foundations
for competent scouts. Do you know of any similar podcasts that are aimed at younger
scouts, Katie? thanks so much for your kind words of support. I am very happy to hear from you.
I really don't know of any similar podcast aimed at working with younger scouts in cubs that is
still recording. I know that if you Google PTC media, you'll find a backlog of podcasts about
cub scouting that you may find helpful. As you noted, I work mainly with older scouts, and
that's mostly what I end up talking about. Since I work within the Boy Scouts of America
program, our discussion is usually pretty specific when it comes to policies and procedures.
I think, though, that many of the concepts are applicable, no matter what age scout you are
working with, And, as you say, the main issue for cub leaders is channeling all that wonderful
energy and excitement. I think scouting at any age level is making the most of the moment
and responding to the interests and needs of the group that you're working with and focusing
on their happiness. At the same time, there are things pulling us in another direction.
What do we teach our scouts? Are they moving forward? Are they getting it?
Are they progressing towards the main aim, And how do we know? How do we measure that
And what happens next? And is it really really that simple Part of the answer comes
from experience. Once you've seen scouts progress through the many stages of development
and growth, you're going to be able to better recognize the effect of your work
Now. I personally spent around 10 years working directly with cubs, and you may wonder if you're
making much progress, because they do seem so disorganized and messy and unfocused and energetic.
You sometimes wonder if you've made any difference at all. But if you train yourself
to look closely, you'll see the small things that children see and that we tend to miss.
When you put yourself into the mind and spirit of an eight-year-old
and listen to what they say and feel what they feel, you understand that you're making
a very big difference in their lives. Scouting, at any age, is almost never a giant leap forward.
It's always small steps forward and a step backward, and then running seven yards to the left
and skipping 20 yards to the right. There's so much joy and fun and energy. We sometimes
miss all the good things that are happening. Now you come to have little real idea of
what's going on and what will be like to be scouted. They know that moment, the moment that they're in
right now and maybe, maybe may have some fuzzy idea of what will happen tomorrow. But you work
with them where they are and you build in small steps. You train yourself to see progress because
I guarantee you it's there. Every child needs good, caring people like you and the millions of
other scouters around the world. What you do is incredibly important and the story will only be
told as their lives unfold. I have been around long enough to see this happen over and over again, so
it's easier for me to be confident about the results. But thanks once again for your kind words
and for taking the time to get in touch. Wayne Nemeth is an assistant scout master for troop
216 in Plymouth meeting, Pennsylvania, and he wrote in to say thank you for all you do for
scouters. You re-energize my scouting spirit every time I listen to your podcast, and each
episode is full of encouragement and inspiration and reminds me why I volunteer my time. In the
end, I truly believe that your podcast has helped me be a better leader to the boys. Well
thanks, Wayne. I'm glad to hear that. My question to you is this: what are your thoughts on
becoming a merit badge counselor? I've been thinking of giving even more time to scouting and
I'm thinking maybe being a merit badge counselor would be a good idea. I'd like to hear your
thoughts on what makes a good counselor. Additionally, our troop currently has a
number of adult leaders who are registered merit badge counselor and work with boys
from our own troop. I'm trying to encourage my own son to branch out and work with counselors
who he doesn't already know. Just wondering what you think. Well, Wayne, thanks so much.
I'm glad you're finding the podcast useful and helpful. I say: go for it. Sign up as a
merit badge counselor and see what happens next. I'm sure it's going to be interesting.
Personally, I counsel several merit badges for the scouts that are in my troop.
The number of blue cards I sign a year is pretty small- Maybe three to five, and
sometimes a little bit more than that- but I don't end up counseling a whole lot of merit
badges. I would say that the good merit badge counselor has the same attributes as any good
scouter, but there are some specific things that I think help make a good merit badge
counselor. They're encouraging, They stick to the requirements in a balanced way,
without becoming overly demanding or overly permissive, and they get the spirit
of the whole process. I think it's important as a merit badge counselor to
look for verbs in the requirements and then take them at face value. That seems
to be the easiest way to get things right. For instance, if a requirement says that a
scout needs to tell you something, well, that means tell. That doesn't necessarily
mean write it down on a worksheet. If a scout needs to show you something,
that actually means they need to show it to you, not write it down on a worksheet.
You kind of get my drift there. The ulterior motives of the merit badge
program are at least equally important to the knowledge and the skill from
earning a merit badge. and those ulterior motives are learning to learn,
being able to use the discovery process to learn things about the subject area
that we're talking about with any given merit badge, the opportunities to
associate with adults and experts that you otherwise wouldn't be able to get to
know, and getting a spark of inspiration that could turn into a career or a
lifelong application. So just to bring it all together, a good merit badge
counselor is going to stick to the requirements in a balanced manner, work
with scouts in an encouraging manner to complete the requirements and spark
their inspiration and give them the opportunity they may not otherwise have
to associate with someone who is an advocate or an expert in the
subject matter and to gain some useful skills. Alex Keenan wrote in to ask
this. thanks for taking the time to do what you do.
I love your blog and I've passed it on to several fellow scouts as a valuable
resource. Here's my dilemma: I am a new scout master,
about two months into the job and I have a senior patrol leader, a 14-year-old,
who started a couple weeks earlier as senior patrol leader than I did as
scout master. He ran for office and he was elected
by the troop, but I honestly don't think he wants to be the senior patrol
leader, and a few other scouts have made the
same observation to me. I sat down with him and one of our
junior assistant scout masters last week to ask him how he's doing
and to make sure he really actually wanted the job. He says that he wants the
position and that he's up to it, but when I ask about what
kind of planning he's doing or how things are going,
he seems to be very non-committal and doesn't seem to be able to capture
what his responsibilities are. He seems to be kind of distracted
and I often have to try and find him during
meetings because he's usually just hanging out somewhere with one of his
buddies. How do I get him to focus on his job as the
senior patrol leader and help our scouts? Well, Alex, thanks for getting in
touch and thanks for your kind words of support.
There are any number of reasons that you are seeing what you're seeing.
Let's take a look at a few. It could be the way things are being done.
Are the scouts really making decisions and running everything,
or are they just doing what they are told by the adults?
You know that's an important aspect. If a senior patrol leader is just working
from a script that adults give for them, if they're not able to
actually lead and to train and inspire their scouts
well, they will lose interest in doing that. so that may be one reason.
It could be that this particular scout doesn't apprehend
exactly what the senior patrol leader job means.
or maybe there's something going on outside of scouts. Maybe he's running
into problems. Is he just not interested? Does he
act like this in other situations? You may want to talk to him about that
a little bit. Just be very honest with the kind of
frustration that you're experiencing in the way that he is carrying out his
responsibilities. You note that you've only been
scoutmaster for two months and that's very, very new.
Unless you're a brand new troop, I'm assuming that you replace someone
else who was the scoutmaster before you. so you represent a change
And scouts, like every other human being on the face of the earth,
don't always like change. They will identify you personally as the chains
and it may take them some time to warm up to the idea that you
are now the scoutmaster. You may be experiencing a little bit of
resistance in that area. It's not a judgment of who you are as a
person or your personality. It can hurt your feelings a little bit,
but it softens the blow to understand that it wouldn't matter who took over for
the old scoutmaster. That person is going to encounter
a little bit of difficulty in the initial months of that change.
So, Alex, let me know if any of that seems to strike a chord and we can
move on from there and maybe I can give you some more advice.
If you have a question, you can get in touch with us and you're going to
find out how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thanks so much for listening to this edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch: Read the Scoutmaster blog at
scoutmastercgcom and, while you're there, you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog by email. You can subscribe to the Scoutmaster
podcast on iTunes and you can access the podcast on your mobile
device through Stitcher Smart Radio. Get details about how to do that at
stitchercom. There is an Android app available
at Google Play. Look for scoutmastercgcom
in the Google Play Marketplace and you'll find the Scoutmaster CG app
and you'll be able to access the podcast and the entire backlog of the podcast.
Eventually, we're working on it. using the app, You can experience all the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
Join the 4000 plus who follow us at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
the 800 or so people who follow us at Scoutmaster CG on Twitter.
You can watch us at Scoutmaster CG on YouTube
and, for admittance to the exclusive Scoutmaster CG circle,
search for Scoutmaster CG on Google Plus. If all of this social media stuff
doesn't appeal to you, that's alright, Bunky, You can zoom into the late 90s and
send me an email. You can get in touch with me at
clark at scoutmastercgcom. That's C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom. The Scoutmaster blog and the
Scoutmaster podcast are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America
Northe and Door Store sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America. No, it's just me
with a microphone and a little spare time, trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way. And speaking of fun, before we leave
you let's hear from our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and group camping. Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.